all right guys
bang bang i've got josh here thanks so
much for doing this man thanks pomp it's
great to be here
and uh great to be in miami yeah for
sure uh you are a former navy officer
and you served in the national security
council
uh let's just start first with military
experience like what'd you do in the
military and then what got you
interested in uh going on to the
national security council
yeah i did a lot of uh middle east sort
of
intel ops work i got recruited out of
college to join
uh interesting corners of the navy and
uh
did two tours in iraq and then when i
wasn't deployed was working on
tech policy so helped stand up the
defense innovation unit
which is the dod's embassy based kind of
function
in silicon valley and this was like an
outpost i think
uh i'm gonna mess this up but there was
a uh
maybe the secretary of defense ash
carter is that right yeah
that's right uh when i was working at
facebook in 2014 or 2015
uh he came out there and he met some
people at facebook most of the veterans
uh and there was kind of a big effort to
set this up right
yeah so i wrote a bunch of uh white
papers back in 2013
just talking about how this was a big
challenge that we had to figure out how
to work with
silicon valley with startups shorten
that time between
innovative technologies coming to market
and the department of defense using them
and so there were a bunch of people
involved that was just one of them but
uh yeah by 2015 we stood up that effort
uh full time
very cool and then national security
council uh what exactly
is that i think people hear it but
they're just like all right uh explain
yeah yeah it's um it's very
uh it's very hard to explain because you
have to have
a lot of knowledge of the details of how
the us government like works
but you can think of it as like a
traffic cop for national security
decision making processes
so anytime there's a really complex
decision that needs to be made
if the president doesn't want to make it
the president can delegate it down
or take a recommendation from specific
members of the cabinet like
the secretary of defense the secretary
of treasury secretary of energy
uh the director of the central
intelligence agency and a bunch of other
folks
the president can say hey what do you
think about x
like should we go do this really complex
risky thing
if they want to get recommendations they
can delegate down to their
deputies and if those people want
recommendations they can delegate down
to subject matter experts inside those
departments and agencies
at every step of that decision-making
and recommendation process
the national security council staff
writes the decision memos
organizes the meetings writes the
recommendation memos that come out of
those meetings and runs those meeting
processes
and so it sounds like you're sort of
doing a lot of paperwork what it ends up
being
is that nsc staff end up coordinating
most national security most national
security decisions and actions and
strategies
that the president wants to execute and
how much of this is like uh
for discussion purposes right so uh the
president or somebody else who's high
ranking they want to
better be informed or kind of solicit
feedback
uh they come to the national security
council there's a bunch of discussion
there's a bunch of kind of information
shared
uh and then really it's not an
organization that sounds like that kind
of
uh has a vote right and it's like yes no
and there's an action taken
it's more so an information gathering
exercise and that discussion that
informs the decision maker
and the decision maker still is the one
who makes the decision so it's actually
both
okay the president can delegate down uh
and say hey
you make this decision at the same time
in fact there are a bunch of like
votes and so sometimes it'll be like hey
the secretary of energy and the
secretary of defense recommend that you
take course of action a
and then like the head of cia and you
know the head
of homeland security believe you should
go for
you know decision b and then you'll like
write up that memo and take it to the
president and be like what do you want
to do a or b
and so in many cases yeah there are like
big fights that happen and then in many
other cases you're right it's just
advisory
and the president will ask uh those
members of the cabinet on the and on the
national security council hey give me
some recommendations how should we
proceed here
but it really is up to the president so
each president gets to sort of craft a
national security council that they want
and you were supposed to focused on
cyber for the most part yeah so
cyber supply chain telecom and then when
we had to do crypto things
and it was mostly at the end i handled
that as well got it and so just talk a
little bit
about you know some of the things that
people were talking about when you think
of national security right you think a
lot about uh kind of
direct action uh in combat or you think
of
um you know the cia the military right
like that's the national security
yep but when you hear cyber or you hear
supply chain
you hear cryptocurrency like that's not
what most people think from a national
security standpoint so like what are
those conversations like what are the
topics that people cared about
uh how informed are people on some of
these topics you have to remember
that when you're a member of the cabinet
when you're the secretary of defense
when you're the secretary of the
department of homeland security
in many cases you may be a subject
matter expert in one
area but you're overseeing these
organizations that are incredibly
complex
and the selection bias for people that
end up getting to those types of places
is often that
they've proven their chops as a subject
matter expert and then they've moved
into some kind of
management and so in many cases these
people are being asked to decide topics
that
maybe up until a few weeks before that
meeting actually happens they haven't
really touched
and so it's the job of the nsc staff and
then the staffers at those departments
and agencies
to get those and they're called
principles to get those principles ready
for that meeting to make sure that
they're getting all the
intelligence briefings all the
background briefings that they're gonna
need
in order to then come into that room and
make that decision
and then sometimes those people are just
so jam-packed they're doing so much from
a day-to-day basis that like
and this is what the nsc staff ends up
doing
they'll get a two-page briefing memo on
the drive over to the white house
and they'll read that and then they'll
walk into the room and they'll have to
have that conversation
and that's why the nsc staff plays a
really critical part
in many administrations because instead
of just bringing people into a room
and like the cabinet the national
security cabinet which is also known as
the national security council
you can imagine they come into a room
and someone says bitcoin
what do you think and then a bunch of
people start talking instead
what the nsc staff tries to do is narrow
down those discussions to like a single
point of contention
and so in many cases you have long
processes for like months
in some cases years where people are
literally trying to figure out
what's the thing we need to decide
what's the thing that maybe only the
president can decide
and then you have those conversations at
increasingly senior levels
so that when it does eventually get to
the president or when it gets to the
actual national
security council the actual cabinet
members that advise the president on
foreign policy
they have very specific things that
they're discussing yeah and what seems
so fascinating about this
is um something like cryptocurrency is
probably not very well understood right
so you need staff members who
are doing education yep uh then they're
identifying like hey here's all the
things we all agree on right right like
this asset exists right this asset is
you know worth x dollars like you know
whatever uh but then there is obviously
the lesser known the topic probably the
more
there is that is either disagreeable or
decisions that need to be made
and maybe let's use the unhosted wallet
that was probably the most public thing
that i think the
national security council was involved
in at the
end of the last administration basically
there was
rumors i don't know if there was
actually any uh kind of regulation
proposed but but it was spoken about uh
of
regulating these unhosted wallets so
talk through using that as an example of
like
where the national security council
plays and then like how you saw that
situation unfold this is a perfect
example so
what happened was that the department of
treasury was debating issuing
um a a rule a regulation
and uh something was released and so
the job of the nsc in a situation like
that
is to circulate amongst the decision
makers hey here's the piece of paper
that this agency is thinking about
putting out
and then if other people have equities
in that topic
the meeting is where they can air those
concerns and so while
um you know i won't get into the
specifics of a of the
then there was a meeting and i was the
person in that meeting as the staffer
that was trying to organize that meeting
and get people on the same page this is
what the discussion is going to be
um so won't talk about what happened in
that meeting but at the same time it's
that process
of like getting people together making
sure that they're all on the same page
they understand
and there was a proposed rule that came
out very late and so
um that's the thing that resulted from
that meeting that the department of
treasury was considering
um and and so that's what an nsc process
looks like you have a department that's
thinking about
doing something that's well within their
sort of legal remit to do
issue regulations that's what you know
these departments and agencies do
but then when it runs into potential
conflicts with other departments and
agencies
the nsc basically acts as that traffic
cop and it's like okay
you want to do x this other department
has a concern about why
so how are we going to sort of find
either some
a compromise or maybe there's not going
to be a compromise and
when everybody comes together and we
break down the issues we take it up to
the president the president's going to
say actually we're going to go
100 in this direction as opposed to this
other direction got it
and so this seems to be the exact uh
opposite of where like cryptocurrencies
decentralization etc are right it's a
very centralized hierarchical structure
i know you've spent a lot of time
thinking about and kind of
you know really trying to understand
this shift from what i'll call like the
narrative driven world
to something that is more kind of
mathematically based uh something that
is
uh much more focused on incentive
systems and coordination and governance
uh in a decentralized manner and so from
a narrative driven
world uh it really feels like uh small
groups of people
right it's kind of the the first example
uh two is heavy heavy credentialism
right of i went to a certain school
i've worked at a certain place i've got
a certain level of wealth i've got a
certain position within the government
etc so why do you kind of see or you
believe after having sent so much time
right in this kind of
hierarchical world that we are shifting
away from it that we are going to end up
in this more like decentralized world
i think that what we've seen over the
past 20 years and really accelerated
over the past 10 years and five years
is that what the internet is delivering
on is this promise of the
of the of the decentralized world and
whether that was the election of
2016 whether that's the development of
blockchain
blockchain-centric
technologies whether it's bitcoin or
ethereum
or other things like that orbit uh
networks that can
allow people to enjoy some of the
tools that we've come to expect from the
internet in a decentralized way
i think that this is the direction this
is just from my experience where
where things are going and the reason is
because they're
more resilient uh i think that they
allow
people to see the benefits of their
efforts
and so with uh you know un
unlike previously where if you wanted to
be someone and you know pomp you've got
this great podcast with
hundreds of thousands of of listeners
and you've got an amazing
uh email list that nearly 200 000 people
read every day
if you wanted to reach that type of an
audience 10 years ago
20 years ago 30 years ago essentially
you would have had to run
multiple oh never mind your investment
fund right where you get to decide how
to deploy capital
you would have probably had to live
three separate completely separate lives
one in an investment bank or a private
equity firm or something like that
one at a big newspaper uh and then you
know another on a radio station and
certainly
you know there are some people in new
york city that are able to do
things like that but uh the internet
allows you to
to do it much more right and so you know
the past 20 or 30 years and i'm really
preaching on the choir here i know
um but the past 20 or 30 years saw
people build platforms that allowed
people like you to some extent people
like me start to build out those types
of audiences
but those people were still sort of
charging a little bit of rent
and so as we move towards more
decentralized platforms i just think
that people are going to migrate towards
the lowest friction environments
and low-friction environments are things
like bitcoin there are things like urban
there are things like ethereum
et cetera and really what we're seeing
is this
breakdown of the narrative right and the
narrative being
uh you went to a certain school you
worked at a certain place therefore you
must have all the answers right
and i think that uh the internet as
you've described has kind of exposed
some of that
of uh your hero is still a human right
they still put their pants on
one leg at a time like the whole nine
yards um
but also i think that there's been a
number of events
from uh the war on terror to the global
financial crisis
to the pandemic and you know plenty in
between
where people just lose a little bit of
trust right a little bit of faith
and it's not always some massive uh
degradation of that trust or faith but
it's just
a little bit here and there and here and
there and then if you kind of zoom out
you look over the last 20 years you're
like oh wow
we've come really really far in that
loss of trust and faith in these
institutions slowly and then quickly
yeah yeah and so from a credentialism
standpoint
does it just not matter at all is it oh
no wait maybe like the top one percent
of credentials will still matter forever
uh how do you think about you know where
we are with
credentials and kind of how that'll
evolve over time
i think it's sort of a yes and kind of a
scenario
you're still gonna have uh you know the
importance of people going to these
in many cases great schools great
organizations
think about it from the perspective of
the facebook pm
right like you know when i was back in
silicon valley in startup world
uh being a facebook pm meant that you'd
gone through
you know a little bit of formal training
and then a lot of on-the-job rigor
and it meant that no matter who you were
if you had that title people would take
you very seriously as a product person
and i think that um that shows two sides
of the coin like
one there's an expectation of rigor and
so you have
programs like austin allred running
lambda school
where you have anyone can come in they
can apply and they can go through a
training program and they come out and
there's an expectation of rigor
what's that person going to be able to
do at the same time it was like it was
facebook
facebook pm okay i got it this person
must be a rock star
and so i think that you're gonna have
those two kind of worlds
but you know as those pies get bigger
they're gonna be folks that like aren't
facebook pms
but they're going to have built
themselves some massive audience
or they're going to have a reputation
that's derived because
you can you know look at their commits
on github you can
you know see contributions they've made
on stack overflow
and you're going to be like wow this
person's like you know a legit
uh developer they really know c plus
plus they've contributed to these code
bases etc
uh and then at the same time you're
gonna have folks where you're gonna have
that organizational patina
like again they're a facebook pm they're
going to go interview at a startup and
they're always going to have that
gravitas
because of that environment they came
out of and i just think that both these
things are going to increase
or at least be able to co-exist but
i think it's the first one it's that
independent world that people can like
make their own way in without having to
go through these
established organizations that i think
we're really seeing the growth of yeah
when you start to think about the impact
on the centralized entities right
there's some things like let's say a
company or a business right i think
we've now seen decentralized versions
uh remote work in some way is it's still
a centralized company they're still a
ceo from a structure
but you're decentralizing actual
physical presence right
and so we're getting some of the
degradation again um but
what about like the government right in
terms of
is there decentralization happening
within like uh
uh you know the us government is there
decentralization happening within some
of the more legacy types of institutions
maybe that aren't doing remote work just
what is that
impact as this trend becomes more
pervasive the tools become much more
prevalent
uh do you see anything happening there
you know i think it's a huge opportunity
for the united states government to
think through how it structures itself
to
accomplish the missions that the
american people expect it to accomplish
i've heard stories on both sides of this
wall
over the past 18 months where
as government workers have been asked to
stay home and not come into the office
i've seen you know folks have come and
told me about oh x got much more
efficient
and then in many cases oh it's no longer
that efficient
and i think that what we're going to end
up seeing and
just given my experience in the military
and then on nsc
i think it'll take a while um but as we
have
more tools that allow folks to
understand like what
and this is what um you know that
that decentralized world offers is
objective measures of efficiency
i think that you know if we can start to
if the united states government can
start to focus on those
i think you'll see a lot of of
improvement but
i think it's going to take a while yeah
uh authority organizations
uh are another piece of this right where
you can decentralize the actual entities
themselves but also there's almost this
uh
um maybe lack of importance on a lot of
these
authority organizations uh some of his
demographics so younger people always
have just kind of thumb their nose at
some sort of authority whether it was
their parents or or
a school or something else uh but it
does feel like there's a societal shift
under way here right where uh many of
the organizations that we used to put
incredible credence in what they said
and what they did
now maybe they're still important but
they're just not as important and the
trend is not working in their favor is
that your read on this
yeah i think that uh one of the most
important things that we're gonna see
is that organizations that allow for
some
measure of clarity around the data that
they're using to make judgments about
the world and about their business
process
i think that those are going to be
organizations that are going to be very
successful
and so you know people's skepticism
and you know we can talk about that uh
but it exists right people are skeptical
maybe they're increasingly skeptical
and the more raw data that we can and
potentially cryptographically verify
as real that will allow people to
essentially
build their own models on top of models
both in their own mind
and then maybe models out you know in
the digital world and they can say like
look
we can all agree on some set of facts
maybe we don't agree on the conclusions
that we draw from them but we can agree
on a set of facts i think
the more we can drive organizations
towards creating immutable facts i
shouldn't even say creating
recognizing publishing immutable facts
that allow people then think about those
and come to judgment on those i think
that's where um
that's where i'd like to see things go
what's up guys bang bang
i hope you're enjoying this conversation
but before we go any further i want to
quickly tell you about today's sponsor
blockfi blockfy's got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
8.6 apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral you
can use their cryptocurrency exchange
and have no trading fees or you can get
a new bitcoin rewards credit card it's a
normal credit card that when you swipe
you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com
pomp again blockfy.com go check it out
and let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it one of
the areas that the national security
council is probably thinking about a lot
right now
is this whole idea of like ransomware
and essential points of failure
and as we get into more of a
decentralized world i think that some of
these will go away
but we've recently seen a number of kind
of cyber attacks right something that's
right in your wheelhouse
maybe let's just start with like what is
ransomware and like how have the
types of attacks evolved over the last
few years yeah
ransomware is when a malicious actor
installs a malicious piece of code on
your computer
or on your maybe cloud server
and in some way shape or form takes over
or locks you out of
that system and so it can take many
forms
there are famous ransomware attacks that
have happened in the past four or five
years
but but core of what happens is like hey
i can no longer log into my computer
and then the attacker that did that
sends me an email and says hey if you
want access to this you have to pay a
ransom
and so we've seen this all over the
world
there's a famous attack in 2017.
uh not petcha and wannacry these are two
massive campaigns that were undertaken
that locked out
hundreds of thousands maybe millions of
users from their computers
and uh asked people to pay
cryptocurrency
to various accounts in order to unlock
their machines
and so what are they doing they're
simply just locking out of the
machine and they're saying hey you can't
get back in until you pay yeah that's
right
how do you pay if you can't get in the
machine is that a problem yeah maybe you
use some other computer or something
like that
in some cases uh and we have to go back
maybe we can put some stuff in the show
notes but
those attacks actually even if you paid
the ransom didn't unlock those machines
it's
really challenging because again you're
dealing with an anonymous
internet based malicious actor
and you don't even know what their
purpose is some of these ransomware
attacks that have spread around the
world
have been targeted very narrowly but
then they've spread all over the world
you know possibly um you know by mistake
or maybe it wasn't intended to do so but
uh
you know in many cases these things are
uncontrollable i mean they're digital
viruses right that's right they have a
virality to them
that uh whether intended or not can
spread very quickly right yeah the world
became much more familiar with virality
over the
last year or so um talk a little bit
about uh
the recent ones in the united states so
there was this uh one in tampa
uh there was something uh around like
beef uh i think there was a pipeline
attack are they all kind of similar in
nature
but just targeting different types of
infrastructure or how do you
kind of categorize them yeah so
ransomware has been around for a while
and i think what we're seeing now
is it is expanding in terms of the scope
and so what it used to be was hey maybe
someone would lock you out of a computer
or maybe they'd lock you out of a
network or something like that
but over the past really 30 years
we've started to put computers into
industrial control systems so
you mentioned a few big industrial
systems like
tampa bay water treatment facility a
series of meat packing plants around the
world
a brewery the molson coors brewery was
hit
by i believe it was hit by ransomware a
few months ago as well
and then obviously you had the colonial
pipeline attack where
by all reports what happened was that
the
accounting systems at that company were
hit by ransomware
and so there's this change happening
where and the tampa
situation is the only one that i'm aware
of so far
where there was an actual uh attempt and
that was not ransomware by the way but
there was an attempt
to dial in over the internet and change
some of the operating parameters of that
water treatment facility
and so on the ransomware side what you
have is people that are
you know dialing into computers locking
a user out
uh and then in this other situation in
tampa you have
a malicious actor trying to log into
that system and change the operating
parameters
now i think that in some way some of
these trends are going to converge
and what's going to end up happening is
they're going to have these massive
industrial infrastructures
where the attacks they may or may not go
after the
computers that the humans are using but
they'll go after the computers that are
actually
governing the process that makes the
thing that generates the capital for
that undertaking
and so it's like you know sure you could
go after
the um the ceo's laptop
but if that ceo is the ceo of a giant
meat processing facility and that actual
equipment that's processing the meat
all of a sudden doesn't operate like
that's a real problem
yeah so it's almost like getting into
the ceo's computer maybe you can get
some ransom or whatever
but if all of a sudden you shoot on the
operations of the business uh and
essentially what you're trying to do is
you're trying to get to the most
critical piece of infrastructure
and if you take that out then all of a
sudden you got everyone's attention
exactly and not only is it a problem
in in the short term but that equipment
is super expensive right it's
it's a big capital expenditure it costs
a ton of cash and if you have to replace
that i mean you're going to really hit
the a company's bottom line
most of these are asking for dollars
cryptocurrencies some other form of
compensation
yeah usually it's crypto um and then i'm
sure there are other examples that i
don't have but obviously
crypto is really easy for these folks to
ask for
and then because the crypto is sent in a
public
ledger uh is it pretty easy to track
down
where it goes from there is there a way
to basically use that to like catch who
these people are do they usually not get
caught that kind of
what's the maybe like the law
enforcement angle of this i mean that's
a really interesting part which is that
you know
the uh many of these currencies bitcoin
especially the
the chain is you know people can see who
owns what
uh coins and so yeah in many cases they
are asking for
bitcoin and while i can't get into how
law enforcement or the intelligence
community goes after
uh folks that are doing these types of
illegal activities and they are illegal
um
yeah i mean that is one thing that is
you know somewhat good
uh it's not a sort of bearer bond or
something where you can just sort of
walk away with it and a few years later
um you know use it or redeem it got it
um
these industrial control systems i think
most people
uh would think of oh the you know meat
processing plant or
uh a water facility for a water company
but they also
are like the electrical grid in a major
city
right like it seems like that's a pretty
similar type of thing
and if all of a sudden you can take over
the electrical grid and shut down
electricity in the city
like maybe mass chaos doesn't happen
immediately but
you know you only have to go a couple of
hours if not a day or two and you're
gonna have mass chaos
yeah it's a big issue and uh there are a
lot uh
there are there's a lot of attention
that's being paid to it so
uh the new administration has done some
great things on this topic they've got
some new orders out some new
instructions we did a lot of work
on this uh as well trying to shore up
and secure those systems
it's something that a lot of people are
paying attention to not only in the
government but then you've got
great companies outside of the
government that are building amazing
technologies to try and
prevent these types of attacks from
happening or find them and very quickly
remediate them once they have
is the electrical grid like the most
important
is it nuclear reactor
you know energy plants like and and some
of this you may not be able to talk
about but just like what types of things
are like the really big things that
everyone knows that's in this world like
hey we gotta protect you know a b and c
um there's a there's a lot of important
stuff out there and a lot of it's
connected to the internet and so i think
that
one way to sort of judge this is you
look to see where
uh where the government is spending time
trying to buy down risk
okay and so um sort of nerd out for a
minute you can look at some regulations
that have been put out by the department
of energy
and they have been for many years
talking about the cyber security of the
electrical grid and in fact
there are a bunch of requirements there
where if you're operating on that grid
you have to
do certain things from a security
standpoint got it and
uh and i think that what is going to end
up happening over the next few years is
more and more of those types of
regulations will come out for critical
infrastructure sectors
of which uh there are many as like
officially defined by government uh
government documents so energy is one
like what are some of the energy is one
you can think of
chemicals as well so like the chemical
industry then you could think of
like uh pipelines you could think about
transportation
um but uh yeah there's a ton right i
mean
think about it everyday life like if you
had to unpack
um if you had to unpack everything that
you do on a day-to-day basis and ask
like how many
times does that process that allowed me
to do that thing touch the internet
i don't even know how you do i live on
the internet yeah literally
yeah you're your house your security
system
your car the gas that filled it you know
the
supply chain that allowed that you know
automotive company to make that thing i
mean jesus
so this is uh i'm just thinking of this
so bear with me if this is a ridiculous
uh question example but uh we're talking
about these kind of uh
control systems and um i forget what
movie or tv show or whatever but i've
seen
the example multiple times where
somebody puts like a pacemaker
yeah right and then it gets hacked and
then there's all sorts of issues with
that
uh in some crazy way like that's the
control system for the human body
and it's connected to the internet right
no very small
portion of people have this real though
a lot of these pacemakers have
bluetooth uh you know transmitters in
them and are running firmware
and like how often are you gonna update
the firmware on someone's pacemaker
right
and the fda pays attention to this but
it's a huge issue
medical devices i mean we go down a
rabbit hole here but you're absolutely
right
and is there a concern there that like
uh i guess remotely somebody could
affect like all pacemakers
from a certain manufacturer or is it
more so uh what i'll consider like uh
the targeting of an individual i know
that you have a pacemaker if i get
within proximity it can pick up the
bluetooth
then that's the bigger problem it's a
weird world we're getting into and i
imagine that probably you've got a bunch
of these types of things that
not only people are thinking about today
but are going to be
challenges tomorrow yeah it's uh it's
fascinating when you start to think it's
just like
what are the things connected to the
internet that we would not want to be
affected
yeah it's a lot
[Laughter]
all right i want to talk about uh kind
of how we fix some of these problems
um both short-term and long-term
solutions uh
to do that maybe let's talk about uh
this tampa
situation um there's a water treatment
facility
yep that basically the control system
gets
hacked uh with ransomware or not with
ransomware just someone
literally dialed in okay and tried to
change the mixture of the chemicals that
were treating the water
oh so not even like pay me just like
like basically i'm a non-economic actor
right and i'm just kind of like screw
with you
how do they get in there i don't know if
you know we're not and then like
what are the ways that we can basically
solve that short and long term
so there are a lot of best practices
that have been put out that government
puts out the private industry puts out
a lot of it has to do with like how you
protect and segment those types of
systems
uh how you conduct maintenance on them
like are you updating them regularly
um how are you attaching new computers
into the networks that are governing
those systems
um honestly and you know you'll know
this from your time in the military and
from my time in the military as well
like the basics get you very far
and uh this is not new you know my
predecessor said this
my successor talks about this all the
time um on the nsc
where if you are if you have basic
hygiene
if you are structuring your networks in
like a reasonable way like hey
you know maybe we shouldn't raw connect
the computer that's controlling
the mixture of chemicals that are you
know going into the water supply of 20
000 you know floridians right to the
internet things like that um
you can protect that
the low-hanging fruit you can protect
yourself against those sort of like
drive-by types of attacks
i think um first of all obviously you
have to go
and protect these types of systems by
using best practices
and then as you move up that chain like
once you've done the basics you can
start to do
more elaborate things you can monitor
the networks
monitor the endpoints you can start to
think about um
looking at the standard behavior of like
that water treatment equipment
you can start to set parameters like hey
if you see it move out of like this
baseline
let someone know almost like an alert
system that hey we might not be able to
prevent everything
but the next best thing to prevention is
like immediately knowing
exactly and so what you have today
across this environment
is people building companies that are
sending
alerts one at a time maybe on one set of
equipment or another
and uh and over time what we're going to
see is
people are going to start to looking
looking at all of those alerts and then
they're going to start to
use big machine learning algorithms and
they're going to start to
figure out like what does normal
behavior look like what does abnormal
behavior look like and that's that's
where we're going so
you know you have a very almost manual
uh environment today
and i don't mean manual because there
are there is a lot of digital
instrumentation many of the companies
that make this equipment
you know siemens rockwell abb general
electric
i mean they're they're highly digitized
um
uh but the point is is that in many
cases they're not
uh they're not you're not able to take a
look at the entire infrastructure all at
once
and so like over time i think you're
going to see instrumentation that
happens on top
people start to build out models of like
what's normal behavior
out to you know how many sigmas of like
average behavior like hey in 99 000
situations like this looks normal to us
here's like the one scenario that looks
abnormal
that's where i think we're going yeah it
feels like um
some of this is very obvious but a lot
of the nuance
and the things that are probably the
most valuable are not very obvious to
those who
don't understand the problems don't
understand kind of how uh
kind of complex these control systems
are right something as simple as just
hey we should monitor and if it goes
without outside of some band like let us
know okay makes sense
when you start getting into the actual
like ph levels of the water
right super complex super nuanced and so
i guess
is it the belief that like you're going
to get vertical specific type solutions
right so like somebody's gonna go build
whether it's a company a government
whoever
okay here's the security apparatus and
software for uh water treatment plants
and then a completely different team
will go and do it again
for electrical grid or or whatever or do
you think that there's going to be
more kind of horizontal software built
where it's just it doesn't matter if
you're
the water treatment plant or the
electrical grid so many of the
components are similar and therefore you
can actually get software that
uh is more applicable to rather than
just one vertical i think you're gonna
see
the one and then the other i think
you're going to see the stuff being
built
for specific industries in fact it's
happening now
and then over time you're going to have
people build out that additional layer
of software
that's going to essentially be much more
of a swiss army knife
and uh and even that's happening now got
it
uh let's talk about bitcoin before we
stop
i expected this yeah uh what just what
are your thoughts on bitcoin in general
let's just start there
and this you personally this is not
anything anywhere you've worked or
anything yep uh i'm a big believer in
decentralized systems i'm a big believer
in
decentralized stores of value
decentralized compute
and i think as many people are observing
in this past weekend here in
miami has showed um you know there's a
certain degree of inevitability around
this if only because people are looking
for ways in which they can
preserve that which they've earned
themselves and then
even you know getting away from
specifically bitcoin but other
cryptocurrencies like go out and earn
and and demonstrate and build value yeah
when you think about that asset um
and let's say that it's going to coexist
with a bunch of other assets
uh is there a
like national security component to this
of embracing it or not embracing it
is there an economic uh is there some
sort of like societal implication that
really
uh kind of interests you or do you think
it's just the the complexity of all
these different disciplines and that's
really where your interest lies
my thesis is a lot around
the decentralization of so much of our
society that as i think about that
thesis
bitcoin cryptocurrencies distributed
compute they just really fit into that
world view of where i think technology
is going over the next 15 and 20 years
and uh you know whatever personal
uh value judgments i may have on
on that trend really it doesn't matter i
i do think that this is just
happening uh inevitable i mean you we
saw a country
uh literally yeah el salvador uh
say that they were gonna i think
consider there's a law that they're
gonna try and pass
but um you know i think more that's
gonna start happening
especially as you know we've seen a lot
of uh
central banks deal with the past few
years with monetary policies that like
average folks may not have really
understood but maybe if they
knew and some do maybe they don't agree
with it and they're going to vote with
their pocketbooks
i forget what the uh the quote is but i
think it might be henry ford says you
know if people understood how money
worked to be rides in the street before
morning
right like it's pretty uh
uh not a new phenomenon right but but
that's one of the things that i think is
really interesting about this is
uh if you go all the way back in history
this is a
story as old as time it just happens
that now we've got digital platforms uh
like twitter and and various other
platforms that just
kind of expose it faster into wider
audiences et cetera
yeah super weird i i wrote a paper back
in college
on um on uh the indian subcontinent
and uh like the 18th century and the
the british and uh
same story you had small principalities
that were devaluing their currency
and it caused a lot of upheaval on the
indian subcontinent
and there there are precedents
throughout history where these types of
things have happened and i just think
that
you know uh something that we have to
pay attention to
i um i also think a lot about uh one of
my favorite documentaries
ever uh is the men who built america and
uh it's the history channel right and
they've got uh rockefeller and carnegie
and just
all of them and i forget uh who did it
but at one point there was essentially
uh a war over the equity
of maybe it was like carnegie steel
right and
uh whatever the business was uh let's
say it was
just for uh kind of illustration purpose
let's say was carnegie steel
carnegie all of a sudden then went and
said wait a minute you're buying up
stock
and you start to print more and more
stock certificates right like
physically print right to then dilute
the
adversarial action of somebody buying up
a stock trying to get any
uh controlling steak and i think about
that happened all the time until
investors got smart i said wait a second
we're going to create an anti-dilution
clause right
right you cannot kind of maliciously
dilute me
without you know these protections we
don't have that with the currency we
literally have that with equities but we
don't have that with currencies
and it's not a us dollar thing like that
is just the structure of
currencies around the world right and
100 plus currencies around the world
they're all the
structured the exact same and so it's a
very unique thing
that i think currencies specifically get
a treatment that maybe other types of
assets don't get whether because
they're physical in nature right because
they're really hard to produce
or there's you know investor protections
that
uh you know just don't allow for it
right
yeah i think this just goes back to a
comment that i made earlier which is
like
what can we do what can organizations of
authority do and it's like
publish clear sets of facts let people
decide
and so again okay we're conducting our
lives denominated in
u.s dollars and you know
people aren't thinking about that and as
they start to realize that that's what
they're doing i think
you know they may start to wonder you
know what are some other structures
uh that could be used and uh you know
maybe they'll come to some other
conclusions about
about how they want to do that how they
want to store their wealth how they want
to spend their wealth
yeah it's um it's fascinating world yeah
the whole move from centralization to
decentralization i think is uh
inevitable to some degree uh there will
be a spectrum
of uh types of decentralization again
you may have a hierarchical structure at
a company
we should get remote work all that and i
think one of the
pieces uh that we don't think a lot
about right you have experienced that
most of us don't
which is how do those centralized
entities that
um it's nearly impossible to see a
government for example becoming
decentralized
right how do they navigate this world
and some of it may just be
there at a level where it doesn't matter
right i always joke and say
uh higher education probably in trouble
right from a long
you know trend perspective ivy league
schools
probably gonna be the last ones left
right like they're the they're the ones
who probably don't have to worry so much
about the disruption
it's the you know tier two or tier three
school in the middle of nowhere that
like
writing's on the wall you know you
probably should be figuring out how to
disrupt yourself now
um and so it feels like governments are
similar to the ivy league schools where
just
they're gonna be the last ones from a
centralization standpoint that uh that
have to worry about some of this
i think that you know in many cases
governments have been this like dominant
power paradigm that we've lived with for
humanity's lived with for
thousands of years and so on some level
there is a need right there's you know
collective defense uh
there's you know propagation of law and
order and so as i think about like what
the future of these types of power
structures
looks and feels like um you know i
i think to some like great sci-fi
authors that
that have been talking about these types
of things for years neil stephenson
with the baroque cycle and kryptonomicon
and other other books in that vein
thinking about like
how do those types of organizations
evolve how do governments evolve like
what are going to be the things that
that peoples are going to demand ask you
know of their governments to do and i
just think that
decentralization offers really
interesting
potential futures and so look it's going
to be
it's going to be a brave new world yeah
what are you most excited about with
crypto kind of moving forward
is there like one or two things that
you're like hey when this happens
that'll be really big
or uh something that you're specifically
uh kind of watching yeah on the security
side
uh biology srinivasan put out a really
interesting tweet storm a few days ago
talking about the future of security
talking about
bug bounties and and things like that
and just in as an example a bunch of
friends and i
have a small little like group chat that
we
that we run and we just started talking
about the mechanics of what it's going
to look like when we can build these
what now seem like very novel uh
security systems and
one fact sort of stood out at me which
was that
you know right now due to the
complexity of blockchain technologies
there's sort of like a limit as to
what types of file sizes can usefully be
stored on chain
and that that in and of itself is sort
of like a bounding condition
around like what we can actually do from
a security perspective
because right now a lot of security
technology relies on
a lot of information flowing across a
system
and it was this moment where i think
at least in this little chat a bunch of
us and you know there's some crypto
people in there there's some security
people some venture people
in there and um you know my reaction i
put this in the chat is that you know
this must be what it felt like
20 years ago when people were looking at
the internet and they were like oh yeah
of course at some point there will be
like
high def full motion video live
streaming from like
you know uh device a to device b over
the telecom network
and we're just now getting there like
you know 17 18
19 years later where you have like 4g
lte
5g technology and yeah now you can get
like live stream 1080p on your
on your phone um and so thinking about
like the the useful file sizes that can
be
you know deployed or utilized over these
you know distributed systems right now i
think we're
i think we're going to need to see the
same type of growth that we've seen over
the past 20 years
in terms of like ability to handle
complexity file sizes transmission rates
things like that
but like we'll we'll end getting there
like biology's vision is
absolutely one one type of future
scenario
where and what he envisions is software
being published
on chain and people who identify
weaknesses in that software um
through you know whatever and nobody's
created these oracles yet but it's like
you'd build oracles that would like
validate this person this researcher had
found a weakness in the system
and then immediately was essentially
like paid out a bounty
for identifying that weakness and then
people can see oh
the the team that's maintaining this um
you know this protocol has fixed the
weakness that was identified and all
that happening
very quickly in near real time and i
think that that's like
a definite possibility but it's going to
take a while
yeah it's um it's very interesting how
the world gets rewired when you
take what is probably the core
mechanism which is centralization uh
because we've pursued
efficiency low cost you know the
corporation itself
right is uh kind of the the ultimate
manifestation of centralization
um and then you start to unbundle it
again
yeah right if you kind of think there
were no multinational corporations you
know
uh thousands of years ago for the most
part
it was a bunch of merchants all over the
place right they were all local
businesses
and then you got that centralization and
are we about to go through the
unbundling
um i don't know i don't think anyone
actually knows
exactly how this plays out uh but it
seems like we're probably more likely to
head that direction than not
yeah yeah i know i think you're right
and i'd be remiss if i didn't mention
one of my
favorite people writing on this topic uh
entrepreneur
in his own right very successful jordan
hall
and we can put some links to some of his
writings in the
in the show notes as well but jordan's
been writing
really interesting stuff for many years
on like what might the implications of
these things be and
again i think offers compelling visions
of the future yeah that's awesome
uh before i let you go three questions
for you then you get to ask me one
uh what's the most important book you've
ever read
kryptonomicon why
it tells a story of what happens when
information transforms from
one state to another
and i think that's in some way shape or
form what's happening now
interesting and so kryptonomicon is
these like for for those folks that
haven't read it first of all
they should read it um but it's these
two stories told one during the second
world war and it's kind of sci-fi
neil stephenson uh second world war and
then this like
and he wrote it in advance you know
before i think he wrote in like 90
in the late 90s uh but then he tells the
story of the emergence of a
cryptocurrency
in like uh early 2000s and
the characters in both timelines are
like the children of
the of the second world war timeline
there's great military stuff in there as
well
but in the second world war timeline
they're talking about
this transformation of information
they're talking about cryptography
code breaking um and
uh and how information has been
transformed from like
physical stuff into like digital stuff
and they're discovering like what does
that actually mean
right they're like listening for
submarines they're listening for encoded
mesh
messages and they're turning that back
into sort of like you know human usable
information
from digital information back into like
physical information
and then that same you know that same
book in that second timeline
they're taking money and they're turning
it into a digital concept
and so in both timelines stevenson is
talking about like
what does it mean for the transformation
of the form of information
in one case it's like raw information
intelligence information military
information
and the other it's like information
about value and so
um i've i've read cryptonomicon
i think uh five times at this point and
it's just one of those
books that like you know it's really
well written it's super exciting
especially for a military guy
uh and i love it that's awesome
suggestion no one suggested that one yet
uh second question comes from our
friends at eight sleep uh i sleep on
their thermoregulated best
yeah i used to sleep like five six hours
i'm like eight nine i literally
uh got the notification on my phone
today i slept nine hours and 40 minutes
last night yeah
which uh life-changing yeah to say the
least yeah
uh what's your sleep schedule like and
uh how's that evolved over time
yeah so um i
you know back when i was in the military
it was like five six
hours you know like going really hard
and then um
yeah in the past four years i've i've
tried to transition over to like
sleep more and i've definitely been
looking at the eight sleep mattress so
uh
fantastic yeah the uh the uh
the influence campaign's working
i tell mateo i'm signing up as soon as i
move out of dc in the next few weeks
as uh as matteo has known i started
asking this question on here
and uh he started laughing he was like
dude like one out of every three people
like i already own one
right i was like wow uh i think it's
just something in the tech
community right like there's a product
that uh the user experience like works
for them
yeah all right i gotta i gotta do one of
those uh
you know they've got those bungalows
that they're renting out so like that'll
be the that'll be the kicker that is uh
that is definitely what it goes try
before you buy yeah yeah
uh third question is aliens are you a
believer or a non-believer
agnostic at this point i think that uh
were you a previous non-believer
and recent information has made you
agnostic i mean look you've got the law
of large numbers and the universe is a
big place
so i think you know you can come to your
own conclusions about that
obviously there's a lot of excitement
today about you know
videos that people are showing and stuff
and i guess just from
from my personal experience um
i haven't seen anything definitive
that's been in public
um and at the same time like one of the
things that i just kept telling myself
no matter what job i was in
is like you don't understand
uh reality you're only striving to
understand reality and it's like
every time i thought i understood
something or like a person's motivation
or like i think this person did this
thing behind the scenes and then once
you actually get there
you realize that like reality is much
more complex right like whether it's
like
crazy advanced technologies that people
are working on or whether it's just like
weird um you know camera angles
like uh i i haven't seen anything yet
um but what i what i do know is there's
like a lot of strange stuff that happens
in the world like
some of it uh i imagine is done by
government some of it's done by
individuals and i'm just more
in that in that mindset where i just
think when i see something that people
are
saying is this really fantastic thing i
just think
you know there's probably a bunch of
other explanations for what we're seeing
and instead of giving myself that really
quick
like answer like oh it must be x
i just think well you know there are a
bunch of things that it could be
i always go back to they makes it
well they probably exist but they're too
far away for us to ever come in contact
with right which is not the technology
they don't have technology whatever
but also two is the definition of alien
right like ufo doesn't mean alien right
right to uh
uh we didn't understand gravity at one
point now we do right so like that type
of stuff right
um but also uh
it could just be like an insect in the
ocean
right like you know or just i don't know
watch videos of trees
time lapsing or like plants over like
time lapsing and like
they shake they do this they do that and
you're like wow that
super freaking weird you know people who
listen to podcast a lot of heard me talk
about this you do you see the
cephalopod intelligence test no oh
man so a cephalopods like a like some
kind of fish or whatever yeah
i'm not an expert on cephalopods but uh
they gave it an intelligence test
and it had like a higher intelligence
than like a young child
and you're just like okay yeah right
like
octopuses that are like shooting out the
light bulbs in there i mean if you've
seen those videos
yeah you're just like man that thing's
freaking smart yeah yeah so
i don't know uh what one question you
have for me to finish up
yeah where uh
where do you think is gonna be the first
western country
that's going to adopt cryptocurrency on
a day-to-day basis like this uh el
salvador situation
like a developed nation yeah
um estonia switzerland you can see those
two i mean they just tend to be more
forward kind of thinking yeah um
i think that singapore
is interesting i don't know i think i
put them in the developed world right
obviously
and uh it could go either way with them
um so i think those are like three the
big one's gonna be
um you know russia china
yeah they come out say like that that
gets more i think a little bit into the
national security stuff
yeah uh but obviously russia and both
them frankly been talking publicly about
de-dollarizing for a while
and yeah so kind of would fit that trend
uh but i haven't given up hope
on the united states yeah like miami
coin
do uh yeah so like i think that um
i don't think the federal government is
going to go and like the treasury or the
federal reserve's like
we have a great idea let's buy bitcoin
and put it on the balance sheet right
they got like i don't think that that's
gonna happen
uh next right maybe it happens you know
at some point but but not next
what i do think though is very real and
obviously uh the mayor of miami uh
francis swore has been working on it a
couple other places i know that
are thinking about it and working on it
is cities or states doing it
and um i'm not the best person to kind
of go through all the nuances of this
but
there's a lot of people in the bitcoin
world who have written about
kind of reintroducing the idea of we
live in a republic
made up of 50 different states
laboratory of democracy
and the competition actually is playing
out a little bit right now
and so all of a sudden you could see
competition and economic incentives and
all this stuff taking over and then
each politician is competing over who's
more pro bitcoin and
you know there's a senator with laser
eyes there's a congressman with lisa
rice there's now a
president of a country with laser eyes
uh there's a mayor with laser eyes like
does that make laser eyes the like bar
for
progress no but that's a pretty high
you know uh kind of step to take if you
are sympathetic to
uh the asset and what is actually the
most fascinating to me is
how much of it is sympathetic to a
financial asset versus the ideals and
ethos that are kind of
uh intertwined with the asset and i
think it's actually more the latter
yeah right is somebody saying sure the
asset is great whatever
but it's the ideas of freedom and
democracy and decentralization
and kind of innovation and
entrepreneurship like that's the stuff
that i'm really
interested in and so i want to align
myself with that audience and so that's
a
much different thing than just like hey
let's all go by bitcoin yeah right
um which uh they're gonna do too right
but uh
we'll see it's an interesting thought
process of like does a city or state do
it again
uh do does it set your state buy bitcoin
put on their balance sheet before
a developed nation does it i don't know
yeah right like you go either way so i
think that
alone just the fact that we're like oh
it could go either way is a pretty big
uh kind of revelation compared to most
people just think like
the united states federal government or
another country's you know central bank
states are good enough yeah awesome
where can we send people to uh to find
you on the internet so i'm blogging
on my post uh national security council
life
uh thinking about security industrial
control system cyber security and then
uh random thoughts at
uh steinman.substance.com okay and then
i'm on twitter and uh we'll put the link
in the
in the show notes it's our dangerous men
i got it back in 2009.
r a-r-e it's a you know
uh it's a quote from a book really yeah
yeah lawrence of arabia
you know i was like a middle eastern guy
for like 15 years i was
al qaeda before what was cool what what
is the uh quote
do you have memorized yeah but it's like
it's kind of worn out at this point oh
okay
yeah but it's about it's about people
that imagine what the world that could
be
uh the dreamers of the day are are
dangerous men for they can
uh you know essentially like make things
make make their dreams reality and
uh it's this line from seven pillars of
wisdom from
lawrence and it's describing you know
how he's thinking about
um you know taking on this grand
challenge of
fighting the ottomans in the middle east
with like
maybe 300 dudes and he frickin did it
i think the u.s military
understanding of a normal like everyday
infantrymen
i think you're supposed to believe that
you've got the upper hand
when it's one of you versus maybe three
of the enemy and then as you get
you know kind of maybe ranger regiments
is like one of five you know one verse
five
and i remember reading a statistic one
time it was like one one to ten or one
to twelve
for you know our most elite forces and
just thinking about like
that's crazy yeah 300 to versus a couple
thousand it might have been more but i
mean it was
right yeah exactly yeah whole different
world
right and uh yeah it's in hand-to-hand
combat yeah
you know no air support maybe a biplane
like every few weeks
yeah all right man well listen thank you
so much for doing this thanks for having
me hope everyone uh
goes and subscribes to the sub stack and
walk through the game in the future
bang bang right